-Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
You're here.
You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so excited about this.
Today is our ninth anniversary
on "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's right.
Nine years, 1,800 episodes, and
one really awkward conversation
with Nicole Kidman.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, nine years.
Of course, we've had some work
done, so we only look seven.
[ Laughter ]
Nine years, that means the show
is officially halfway
to dating Leonardo DiCaprio.
[ Audience gasps ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no, you didn't.
Oh, come on.
-Our show --
-Come on.
-Our show premiered
during the 2014 Winter Olympics.
That's how long it's been.
We started way back
when there was still winter.
[ Laughter ]
It's a major accomplishment,
and as a thank you
to the entire staff, I gave them
off for Presidents' Day weekend.
[ Laughter ]
The traditional gift for the
ninth anniversary is pottery,
so, later tonight, Tariq
and I will be re-enacting
the scene from "Ghost."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right. We've been on
the air for a whole nine years.
I can't believe it.
A lot has changed since then.
I mean, look, this is a picture
of me when I first started.
That's real. Yeah.
[ Audience awws ]
Here's a picture of you, Tariq.
[ Laughter ]
Can you believe
that was nine years ago?
And here's a picture of you,
Higgins.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Aww.
-That's not --
-A long time ago.
-Nine years ago. Yeah, nine.
Time flies.
Well, as I mentioned,
it's Presidents' Day weekend.
Of course, every family
is different.
Some families get together
on Presidents' Day,
while others celebrate
on Presidents' Day eve.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, not only is there
a long weekend,
but everyone's pumped
for this --
today "Ant-Man And The Wasp:
Quantumania" hit theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Which is great because usually
to see ants at a theater,
you have to go to
go to Regal Cinemas.
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Mimics cigarette drag ]
"Sit whatever you want.
I don't care where."
[ Laughter ]
"My seat doesn't go back."
"Well, I know,
but it goes forward."
[ Laughter ]
Why would I --
Meanwhile, I heard that in
the future, Disney wants
to spread out
their Marvel releases. Yeah.
Disney knew it was time to slow
down when they started making
a movie about The Hulk's tailor.
[ Laughter ]
"I work on his suits
all the time.
I say please don't get angry,
Mr. Banner.
You'll ruin..."
Some news from Washington --
President Biden just had
his annual physical exam,
and his doctor reported that
Biden is "healthy and vigorous."
[ Laughter ]
Even Democrats are like,
"Healthy and vigorous?
Did he go to Trump's doctor?
[ Laughter ]
When Biden left the room,
the doctor was like, "Yeesh!"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Biden's doctor said
he's healthy and vigorous,
but has a stiff gait.
He basically got the same
results as Seabiscuit.
[ Laughter ]
Biden's doctor also said
he had a small lesion removed
from his chest,
which sounds like a polite way
of saying third nipple.
[ Laughter ]
Well, what?
This is odd though --
Biden's actually gotten taller.
This is true.
He's actually gotten taller
since his physical a year ago.
Forget the UFOs. I want to know
how an 80-year-old grew.
What's going on?
Got taller.
[ Applause ]
And everyone's still talking
about this.
Last weekend,
the U.S. shot down three UFOs,
and it turns out one
of them might have been
a $12 hobby balloon
that belonged to a group
called the Northern Illinois
Bottle Cap Balloon Brigade.
[ Laughter ]
So it looks like we've made
a very powerful enemy.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, all this week, people have
been talking about the U.S.
shooting down UFOs.
It feels like we're in
the middle of a --
-I want to shoot me a UFO.
-Excuse me? Excuse me?
-I said, I want to shoot me
a UFO.
Why's the government get to have
all the fun?
I got me great aim
with my slingshot.
[ Mimics firing ]
[ Laughter ]
-You think you can shoot down
a UFO with a slingshot?
-I know I can.
I gotta use my slingshot.
I just got it back
from my teacher.
-Your teacher?
How old are you?
-45.
-You're still in school?
-Yep. My teacher took
my slingshot in first grade,
and I had to re-enroll
in elementary school
to get it back.
-Couldn't you just have
asked your teacher to give back
your slingshot without
re-enrolling in the first grade?
Or buy a new one?
-I don't like your tone, Fallon.
Eat rock.
-Ow.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ] You see,
I told you I got great aim.
I just hit a UFMF, unidentified
flying mother [bleep].
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This crazy.
Get him out of here.
Get this guy out of here.
Let's get this guy out --
-I'll be back, Fallon.
You ain't seen the last of me.
-What the hell is --
What the hell is wrong?
You can't talk like that.
-Oh, my God.
That guy is rude
and had a foul mouth.
-Yes.
-A foul mouth.
-This is a family show.
Who is that guy?
Get him out of here.
-Geez Louise.
Goodness gravy.
-Some business news here, guys.
I saw that the CEO of
YouTube is stepping down.
Yup, when employees heard,
they were like, "First."
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
before her announcement,
she made everyone sit through
a 15-second ad for VRBO.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I read that Peeps-flavored
Pepsi is back.
Yeah. And it'll be available
everywhere this time.
Yep, Pepsi that tastes like
Peeps.
Yes, Tariq?
-Question, does the Pepsi taste
like a Peep
or does the Peep
taste like a Pepsi?
-I don't think it
really matters.
[ Light laughter ]
Yes, Tariq?
-If I had to guess, I'd
say the Pepsi tastes like Peeps.
-♪ Because the Peeps
are in the Pepsi ♪
-♪ And the Pepsi's
in the Peeps ♪
-♪ Pour a pint, pound it down ♪
-♪ And then do that on repeat ♪
-♪ Plop plop, fizz ♪
-♪ It's the perfect
Easter treat ♪
-♪ The Pepsi packs a punch ♪
-♪ And the Peeps provide
the sweet ♪
-♪ Peter piper picked a peck
of pickled Pepsi Peeps? ♪
-♪ Polly Pocket picked a pack
of peppers in her sleep ♪
-♪ The Peeps are so pleasing ♪
-♪ The Pepsi wets your beak ♪
-♪ But the Peeps are in
the Pepsi ♪
-♪ Wanna try it? ♪
-♪ Yes, please ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Both: ♪ Pepsi and Peeps ♪
♪ Filling your cup,
drink it all up! ♪
-Pepsi and Peeps mixtape 2023.
[ Air horn ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-Did you guys see this?
-What?
Starbucks just recalled bottles
of their vanilla frappuccino
because they could contain
glass.
Meanwhile, if it was Dunkin',
they'd just relabel
the bottles "chunky."
[ Laughter ]
Get this,
according to a new report,
we've actually been
pronouncing the names of several
popular brands and companies
wrong for decades.
For example, Adidas is actually
pronounced adi-daas.
It's true.
And IKEA should be pronounced
"e-kay-uh."
-Pfft. Come on. I already knew
that. I knew that.
-Sorry, Higgins. You knew how
those names are pronounced?
-Yeah, I know how every brand
name is pronounced because
I'm an announcer
and that's my job.
So, go ahead and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Go ahead and test me.
-You want me to --
-Give me some names.
-Sure.
I guess I can test you quick.
What's this?
-Come on. Goat cheese.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. What's this?
-Bloomin' onion. Come on, give
me -- give me some hard ones.
Rapid-fire them.
-Rapid fire.
Okay, here we go. What's this?
-Okay. Ham.
[ Laughter ]
Sup Bro.
Magic Mike.
Batman and Robin's.
Ben and J.Lo.
You Go Girl.
Oh, Rihanna's Pregnant.
[ Laughter ]
Chinese Spy Balloon.
♪ So Call Me Maybe ♪
Blue Balls, I Scream.
[ Laughter ]
Hot Tupac.
Bananas Are Pubic.
Herpes.
Diarrhea.
Enormous Rack.
[ Laughter ]
You want me to -- I can't
believe you want me
to read this one on TV.
-Yeah.
-Taint, Balls, and Ass.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, just stop, stop.
Turn his mike off. Just stop.
Get out of here.
No, turn it off.
-A network show!
That guy swore!
-I'm about to get security
to get you out of here.
Terrible.
-My gosh.
-Switching gears,
this is fun.
Today is National Random Acts of
Kindness Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm all for kindness.
I'm all for kindness, but the
random part is kind of scary.
Yeah, I don't need the guy next
to me on the subway saying,
"Here, I made you a meat loaf."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, listen to this,
a boardwalk game operator
at the Jersey Shore has
been banned from running
amusement games for allegedly
overinflating basketballs.
Wait, wait, wait. You're telling
me those games are rigged?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a lawyer is being
sued after she allegedly spent
more than $10 million
of her company's money
in Las Vegas.
The law firm is trying to get
their $10 million back
while the woman says
she's willing to settle
for double or nothing.
We have a great show.
Let's go write
some thank-you notes, come on.